GUNTHER ROLAND:
One of the changes
that we made over the
last three or four
years was to flip the
classroom in 8.13 and 8.14.
Essentially what we found is
that we spend a lot of time
in class with lectures by the
lab staff which in the end
seemed to be only moderately
useful in really getting
the material across.
So what we decided
to do was to export
the lectures in the form of
videos to the MITx platform
and replace the time that
we spent on that previously
with in-class exercises
and class discussions
to really rehearse some of the
concepts that were introduced
in the lectures in class,
which also gives us
a much closer communication
with the students.
And you can find out what
it is that really needs
to be explored in more depth.
The other thing
that we did is move
the prep questions for
each of the experiments
also to that platform.
What is important
there is that we
can give the students
instantaneous feedback
on whether they got the
question right or not,
and remove the manuals for the
labs onto the same platform
to have a lot of
that in one place.
And I think, as I
said, the main benefit
is really that we can use
the time that we free up
in the class for
discussions and exercises
that are much more effective
than the students sitting
there and listening
to one of us talk.